This lesson has illustrated some uses of OCL to provide
precise specifications for simple library information system. Even so
there are many more things we need to do to complete this exercise.
We haven't even mentioned some of the other requirements like numbers one,
three, eight, ten, 11 which we would need to specify. We haven't of course at
all in this whole exercise mention anything having to do with non functional.
Requirements. Along the way we invented some axillary operations like
is available, and is available is actually pretty complicated itself and
we'd have, we'd have to white that out. We'd have to handle some
situations implicit in the requirements such as returning a loanable item,
as returning a book we checked out. Paying a fine, cancelling a request, and so
on. And, we might have to consider some new
some new issues that arise during the course of doing this. For example,
if one item in a title is a best seller, need all of them be best sellers,
okay? It would make sense in a library if you have some. Designated a book as
a best seller that all the items in that title, are a best seller. But
we haven't stated anything explicitly that would require that. We would also
need to op, add in some specifications for operations for classes date. And
money. Money had to do with paying fines. Although in those situations we could
presumably reuse those specification in other systems that we're building.
Likewise, for the operating system operations. We also haven't said
anything about constructing instances of loanable items and patrons. Although,
we did construct instances of associations and we can use similar techniques for
constructing h, the instances of the other two classes.